today's catch is pretty good plenty of
monkfish Cod and tusk I leaf air doll
has been fishing the waters of the fear
death yard for many years after a short
career in the military he decided he'd
rather work and live surrounded by
nature on a beautiful day like this it's
quite impossible to understand that
somebody think is a good idea to destroy
this beautiful scenery I think the only
natural thing to do is to live here and
enjoy the nature as the people here do
or as a tourist the fishermen here are
under pressure from a mining company
that wants to begin extracting a mineral
found in the cliffs of the fjord aired
all fears that if the minors are allowed
to get to work the days of Plenty here
in the few Ord are numbered by the time
operations are in full swing he says
he'll probably be out of a job
they're going to take the top of the
mountain and then they're going to
quarry it out and then they start
tunneling in the worst part is that
they're going to take all the dump the
wastes from the production goes into the
fjord and they will fill it up 150 200
metres and destroying the local life in
the field the Norwegian government has
given the firm Nordic mining a license
to exploit the resources politicians in
Oslo hope the project will create jobs
there's little work to be had in the
region it is about balancing industrial
objectives jobs value creation with
effects on the natural environment and
when in this particular case we have
given authority approval for this
industrial development it is based on a
very thorough environmental impact
assessment people in the village are
very worried together with conservation
groups they're demanding a ban on the
marine disposal of waste from mining
only five countries in the world still
allow it opponents say if the project
goes forward the seabed in the feud will
take generations to recover if it does
at all the company also admit that it
will die but they say it will be will be
the same after 50 years but it will not
it has taken thousands of years to shape
this environment in the sea and all the
animals and all the fish will not be
here some of them will come back but it
will not be the same as it is now Nordic
mining is after the mineral rutile it's
used as a pigment for example to make
the brilliant white and toothpaste the
company wants to extract it for the next
40 years which would create 250 million
tons of slurry
so hold the whole area around us here is
going to be the wasting ground air doll
is also worried the toxic sludge could
be carried out into the open waters of
the North Atlantic many people here rely
on the fjord for their subsistence
around half of era dolls income comes
from either fishing or tourism it means
a lot for me local and you're growing up
I quote my first Simon I was for now I'm
47 and I'm really looking forward to
catch my assignment this year also the
family also runs a cafe right on the
water of the fjord guests come here to
enjoy the breathtaking natural
surroundings and homestyle norwegian
food traditional baked goods and of
course lots of fish the mining company
claims that fishing is little more than
a hobby for the people here that
accusation makes the fishermen angry
it's a selling point that it's a clean
fish so say it's a hobby it's quite
interesting it's more people working
with regarding to the nature here in
this area then the Nordic mining is
providing many of the families in the
area that will be impacted most by the
mine are refusing to accept the
government's decision hundreds of
demonstrators have blocked streets
leading to the site some have been hit
with stiff fines air doll is happy that
his problem is now a topic all over
Norway
despite the opposition nordic mining has
been pushing ahead tracks like these
left by digging equipment are fresh the
boreholes help illustrate exactly how
deep the company plans to go it's a long
way to the bottom I hope this is the
biggest home the other night I leave era
doll hopes that in the end the social
and economic costs of the mining project
on the furtive yard will eventually
cause the company to cave in he dreams
of building and running a hotel on its
crystalline waters one that of course
would serve fish